[Musique]
hiya cam v Myron je peux lèvres ta cuillère
jalousie j'ai dit
au revoir je veux dire saké
je suis à Bakke comme un charlie sens
une cigarette je m'en fous tu es chaud je ne le
suis PAS tu es comme en quittant Las Vegas
tu tues la robe regarde moi mon cul
pour compter le cul fou
[Musique]
Je veux dire les mauvaises herbes comptent
tu es juste un peu
comme toutes les requêtes viennent
ne rien faire au cas où tu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Je
[Musique]
elle a caché du bleu elle a fait la princesse Big D
et ma voiture d'essai
mes étoiles
[Musique]
vous vous sentez
faire l'imprimante de texte rex
Xing Qi Shuai jaloux
Oh
[Musique]
en général